the title of thomas piketty's book is
capital in the 21st century so it's
probably worth having a conversation
about what capital is so if you're going
to produce anything so you want to
produce anything you need some input you
need some factors for that production so
you would put them together so let's say
that you're you are a farm you are a
farm your output is food well what are
your inputs going to be so this is a
farm right over here let me draw a
little circle here farm and your output
is food
what are your inputs going to be well
you're going to need some land you're
going to need you're going to need some
water you're going to need some you're
going to need some equipment equipment
equipment and then you're going to need
some some maybe you might need some
seeds and animals and so I'll just put
generally here supplies supplies and of
course you're going to need people to
put all these things together and
essentially work the land dough to plow
the soil and plant the seeds and harvest
the crops and manage the whole
operations so you're going to need labor
you're going to need labor as well so
you take all of these factors of
production together they essentially
represent a farm that is going to output
food so when people talk about capital
is a factor as a factor of production
sometimes they talk about it in a fairly
narrow way they'll separate things like
land and resources is something separate
but and they'll say capital is hey
that's you know your equipment and your
supplies but when people talk in more
general terms especially in the focus of
this book when we were people talking
about labor versus capital capital when
we just group things in only those two
categories and that in that context
capital would essentially represent
pretty much everything else so this
right over here would be capital and one
way to think about capital it's the
things that you could maybe you
our assets that you have that can be
valued that will give you future benefit
these are thin you can buy and sell
those assets and we can think about
other businesses here or other other
things that are trying to produce
something so let's say you have a let's
say that you have a mine a mine so a
mine so this is the operation and it's
going to produce let's just say it's a
gold mine so it's going to produce gold
so what are the inputs that you would
need there well you're clearly going to
need some labor you're going to need the
miners and the people who would manage
the operation of the gold mine but
that's not that's not all you need you
also need energy maybe to operate some
your equipment and actually I would put
energy in here too some of which comes
from the Sun but some of which you might
have to might have to purchase or have
somehow and then you would also need
equipment equipment and you would need
supplies I mean we could consider energy
supply if you like or you need a supply
of energy but you also might need a
tires or something like that you might
need food in order to to provide for the
laborer who knows what else you might
need in your mind and you also would
need of course land you need access to
land to actually mined so here if we
think in very broad terms you could view
you could view all of this as the
capital all of this as the capital and
of course you have your labor and you
put your labor and your capital together
and you produce you produce the gold now
another idea that you will hear in well
you'll hear in life a lot but obviously
in a book about capital this will come
up a lot is the idea of return on
capital return return on capital and
this is just a measure of given a value
of capital that you have employed how
much income are you getting for that
capital so for example let's say that
let's say that let's say
this farm the total value of this
capital let's just say it is I don't
know I'll make up a number here let's
just say it is 1 million dollars 1 1
million dollars is a total value of the
land and maybe you have access to your
own lake and the equipment and the
supplies here it's one it's 1 million
dollars of capital the value of that
capital is 1 million dollars and let's
say that this the the income of the farm
after you pay the labor
so let's actually let's let's do this in
a little bit a little broader term so
let's say the foods value the food
that's produced is has a value of
$100,000 in the market now out of that
hundred thousand dollars you obviously
have to pay your labor so let's say that
50 thousand dollars of it goes to the
laborer fifty thousand dollars goes to
the laborer and like we were saying this
is in a given year so you use the
capital to labor you produce a hundred
thousand dollars worth of food fifty
thousand dollars goes to the labor
what's going to be return on capital
well you have another 50 thousand left
over for the capital for the owners of
the capital whoever owned the farm so
the owners of the capital would get the
other would get the other fifty thousand
dollars so your return on capital is
going to be fifty thousand dollars
that's what the owner of the capital
gets and it's the return on their
investment of 1 million dollars 1 1
million dollars and this is going to be
this is going to be the same thing as 5
divided by a hundred or it would be five
percent you have a five percent return
on capital you invest a million dollars
you're going to get $50,000 so who's the
six percent return on capital you invest
a million dollars you get sixty thousand
dollars now that we've kind of thought
about that a little bit let's actually
look at a pretty neat chart from the
book and once again it's pretty neat he
has a if you look right over here at
picady dot psee nsfr capital 21c he has
all the charts from his book which is
which make for interesting
analysis at minimum and and and he's
gathered all this all of this
information this is pretty interest is
capital and slavery in the United States
and what's interesting about that is you
when you study American history you talk
a lot about slavery but you to realize
that in the time of slavery as abhorrent
as it as it is and was people viewed
slaves as capital not as labor as they
view them as something that they could
buy or sell that they owned and that
would create future income for them and
this just gives us a sense of kind of
the breakdown of capital over history
you see down at least in the United
States
you see agricultural land in 1770 it was
a reasonable percentage is the value of
capital as a percentage of national
income so the value of the land is a
percentage of national income was much
higher than it is today and we see the
other trend that the other domestic
capital has become much more much more
volume and say well what is this other
domestic capital well this could be
things like like infrastructure it could
be technology it could be mechanical
technology things like trains and cars
and trucks and buses or and factories or
it could be it could be it could be
software it could be computers whatever
else and as we see as we went through
the Industrial Revolution the value of
other forms of technology became or
other forms of capital other than land
became more and more important for for
our economy and obviously slavery ended
slavery ended in the late 1860's made it
mid late 1860's and obviously that went
away but just an interesting way to
think about macroeconomic trends in the
United States land in 1770 was a major
factor of production and still is
obviously we still need land in order to
produce things especially agriculture
well this is agricultural and you still
it's still it's still a major part of a
land has disappeared it's just that the
economy has grown to be much more than
just agriculture so in 1770 agriculture
was a big part of our economy
now agriculture is a much much smaller
part of a car
our economy so this is just a an
interesting way to think about well okay
this is that all of the capital and this
is both public and private capital
included here so public capital would be
something that is owned by the public by
the government while private capital
would be something that is owned by by
private individuals or corporations or
whatever else but you see on average you
have had kind of a fairly constant you
know give or take a little bit that the
total value of the capital has been
around four to five times the value of
the total productive output four to five
times the value of the total productive
output of the country